big fight announcement yeah tank Davis
and now April 22nd are you nervous no no
really no two undefeateds too undefeated
not even an ounce of the nervousness wow
it is a big it's the biggest fight in my
life I just don't feel nervous it's one
of the biggest fights of I mean probably
in a hot second next like three years I
mean last five years this fight has been
like rumbling and rumors it was supposed
to happen and finally you know once the
fighters and that's it you know it's
real it's like it's an insane fight so
Javonte Davis I think was he 27-0
I think 25 Knockouts but he's like show
times like he's he's the main guy
pay-per-view guy and he's a knockout
artist and then you know Ryan is this
young knockout artist undefeated
obviously
you know yeah we're both knockout
Fighters uh I will this into existence
you know I was uh I was so determined to
make this fight happen so like I'm just
so happy it's finally here that's why
I'm not nervous about it because I kind
of manifest I wanted it more than
anything in my life